allora ragazzi finalmente è arrivato
l'ultimo anno è l'anno della maturità
tranquillità e tranquilli per tenga
tutto bene l'importante come che sta in
poi dal per studiare di volta in volta
[Musica]
gli devo confessare che questo è stato
durante il mio viaggio a medjugorie per
il fatto tantissimo mi siete mancati
ragazzi voglio bene stupide fonino
subito e federica meglio esposito male a
casa sua scrive sui tavoli no ecco
e allora perché sta scrivendo sul banco
ragazzi che quel coso volevo far vedere
questo documentario che era bellissimo
nostro sarà il proiettore c'è qualche
volontario che mi aiuta però funzionale
ragazzi guardate che se non mi dire te
la mia elezione potete anche alzarvi
uscire no non sa dove i dati andato deve
dire subito non fate caso alla campagna
è la lezione figli se quando lo dico io
si ragazzi i compiti io qua ma non gli
auguri corretti e voi quelli in fondo di
cosa state parlando
ma sembra molto interessante perché non
ce la raccontate anche a noi magari ci
facciamo due risate né per in usa quando
mi dispiace che il tuo gatto abbia fatto
indigestione
non adesso non mi pare una buona scusa
per non aver fatto i compiti rivede
ridete pure poi a giugno libero io
quando mi vedrò piangere
volete fare una volta per tutte
guai a voi se mi mandano i genitori a
chiedere perché prendete brutti voti
ve li meritate ragazzi perché siete
delle capre e siete anche parecchio
maleducati allora ragazzo appena
corretto i compiti della terza c ne sono
andati tutti benissimo
sono proprio curioso di vedere i vostri
né ranieri io contenuto proprio cosa
fare non studi niente non come tua
sorella lei era una studentessa modello
e rossi lato verificare perfetta ma ti
ho messo 7 e così ti sprona a fare di
meglio
ragazzi continuate pure a chiacchierare
tranquilli dentro tutti i minuti che mi
fate perdere gli tolgo dall'intervallo
no scusate in un capisco perché siate
già mettendo via tutto quando mancano
più di 40 secondi al suono della
campanella ma ringraziato e pure il
vostro compagno se oggi non farete
l'intervallo ha quindi e la cistite
senti io in magnetici mondo cura modo
viene di portare certificato medico
qui compito e pagine per chi ha studiato
ovviamente vaga ci avete capito tutto
chiaro certo tutto java che doveva poi
quando correggeva i compiti vi farò
gaslight avete copiato tutti perfetto
fino a quando non esce fuori cancellino
nessuno e dico nessuno uscirà da questa
classe bernardi vuoi che ti porti anche
un the con dei biscotti
allora ragazzi compiti per domani
segnatevi le frasi che ho dimenticato in
questo video se questo video arriverai
50.000 like allora girerò la seconda
parte alloggiamento ragazzi cioè non
l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
canale se no vi voglio tutti e poi
attivate le notifiche cliccando sulla
campanella vicina al tassa d'iscrizione
ma fatele opinione suoni la campanella
mi raccomando anche se vado a medjugorie
io sono una ragazza come voi sono molto
social quindi seguitemi su tutti gli
altri solita che ci sono su instagram e
ci sono anche su facebook e poi dove
sono su ticket orc che le patch i
balletti e dire ci vediamo al posto di
laika la grande famiglia volta in volta
come per tempo il detto allora vi voglio
dire la verità e durante il mio viaggio
[Risate]
[Musica]
vi devo confessare
[Risate]